I am very aware of the preciousness of
time.
Yeah.
I have spent my life traveling across
the my mind,
true theoretical physics.
I had sought to answer some of the Great
Westerns,
but there are other challenges or big
lessons slips must be answered,
but these little also need a new
generation who are interested and
engaged with an understanding of
science.
I will eat,
feed an ever growing population,
provide clean water lender and renewable
energy,
resentment your disease,
but slow down global climate change.
What up duck arrayed revelation.
Some dumb ass comes up perspective.
It has gifted humanity on ourselves.
When we see the earth from space,
we see ourselves as suppo.
[inaudible] divisions did is such a
simple image with a compelling message
that when human race,
we are here together and we made to live
her with tolerance and respect.
We must become global citizens.
We are all time traveler journeying
together into the future.
Let let us work together or tell me
cause that's a future.
[inaudible] be brave.
We determined over a company that can be
done.
Seize the moment.
No.